Speaker 1: . We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David Pakman.
Here's a really good question about
vaccination via voice mail. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, I was calling because
my mother is a Trumper and I am a Democrat,
I have been vaccinated. My mother refuses to
get it. And my question for you is, do you think
that if Trump would have won the presidency
again and had the opportunity to be on the
big stage to brag about it being Trump's
vaccine? Yep. Do you think more Republicans
would have been likely to get the vaccine?
Speaker 1: Of course. Of course, it is undeniable.
If Trump had won and had figured out how to
distribute the vaccine the way Joe Biden did
and was presiding over what we are now seeing
with the virus, you would see way more Republicans
going get themselves vaccinated. The most
anti covid vaccine group is Trump supporters.
If Trump had said if Trump had won and then when
he got vaccinated in secret on January, whatever,
Trump had announced it and done it publicly and
continue talking about the vaccine. I did it. I
brought you the vaccine way more Trump is would
have been vaccinated. That doesn't mean that
we would be better off with Trump overall,
but there is no doubt whatsoever. Excellent.
Excellent question. You are completely right. We
have a great voicemail. I'm sorry. We have a great
bonus show today. We will talk about the U.S.
recovering millions in the Krypto ransom that was
paid to Colonial by Colonial Pipeline. The FBI was
able to recover a bunch of it. Very interesting.
Republicans are also pledging allegiance to fossil
fuels again. And the Supreme Court has ruled
against immigrants who are in temporary status
seeking green cards right now. Not a good ruling.
All of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. I will see you then. If you are
a David Pakman show member, sign up at Join
Pakman dot com. And remember to subscribe
free to the new YouTube channel. You can
find it at David Pakman dot com Pakman.